one of the best predictors for
pathological use is the age at which you
first become exposed to it how does use
impact a developing brain when you have
a developing brain adding a substance to
it makes us more vulnerable to it long
term so there's even studies that show
that early usage is more likely to lead
to addictions of other kinds and it's
because when you use one at a young age
it actually Alters how your dopamine
circuitry is formed and leaves you
vulnerable to other addictions so my
guess is that he has some similar
neuroscientific mechanism where
something is going on because these
people are prepubescent usually when
they're exposed which means that they
don't get aroused they don't even
understand what they're seeing which is
the most common thing when I talk to
people who are addicted to adding stuff
to the developing brain Alters its
formation but that perfectly shows why
use is at least in part not because you
have this coping mechanism for an
individual who is as yet not